uh meta which is of course the new name
for facebook um
overnight there were reports that um
meta had eased its policy in relation to
um
certain comments about
the russian armed forces that it was not
blocked to make pretty inflammatory
comments about the russian armed forces
and that has caused precipitated a
very rapid response from russia with the
prosecutor general demanding that the
media regulator block all metas
platforms in russia which is facebook
instagram and uh whatsapp
um the prosecutor general making that uh
statement actually on instagram which is
pretty ironic but it shows you how
deep-rooted those networks are in this
country and is another indication of
really how much of a sort of squeeze
there is on the information space you
know here in moscow so much is done on
instagram you book everything on
instagram that will all go at a time
when you can really feel the sanctions
crunch uh coming in so you heard from
vladimir putin earlier that he feels
russia can weather the storm i think it
may take quite a while before um
before we see
you know the storm ending